pas le temps de s'arrêter c'est la
course vers la frontière
la rumeur veut que les portes vers elle
passe au Texas vont ouvrir bientôt
nous sommes à Juan au Mexique à la
frontière américaine
on défait les barbelés pour se faufiler
rien ne peut briser ce rêve d'une vie
meilleure
une fois le premier obstacle franchi il
reste le fameux mur
ils sont des milliers devant la porte 40
aux États-Unis le rêve américain est
suspendu entre des barbelés et un mur
nous sommes ici à Rouen et au Mexique
mais de l'autre côté du fleuve elle rit
au bravo vous vous retrouvez aux
États-Unis depuis quelques jours ils
sont des milliers à avoir traversé la
frontière
et une fois en sol américain ils sont
pris en étau sous un soleil de plomb
sans accès à de la nourriture ou de
l'eau ils font donc les allers-retours
au Mexique avec des provisions
ni à manger ni à boire beaucoup font les
allers-retours
à l'ombre d'un arbre on planifie la
suite Fernando et ses amis attend depuis
plusieurs semaines électricien de
formation il tente de faire une demande
légalement comme le réclame
l'administration Biden mais
l'application des douanes américaines ne
marche pas dit-il ça ne marche pas j'ai
fait plusieurs essais
qui ont réussi à traverser la frontière
se retrouve à El Paso Texas
après avoir traversé la jungle du Darian
au Panama puis les persécutions les
guerres les cartels ils aboutissent ici
à l'angle des rues Oregon et father Rome
c'est le repos des migrants ou presque
car leur avenir reste incertain
Ricardo s'est déplacé la rotule après
avoir marché 4 mois du Venezuela
[Musique]
et puis au beau milieu de cette foule
Louis sandrez 10 ans dort paisiblement
avec une sonde alimentaire
[Musique]
désespéré au Venezuela je n'arrivais pas
à obtenir des médicaments ça fait une
semaine que je suis ici
un père célibataire dit-il il fallait
que je sorte de mon pays pour l'avenir
de mon fils et pourtant il dort dans la
rue avec une plaie béante dans un
anonymat total
l'entrevue est interrompu c'est l'heure
du nettoyage il faut évacuer disent les
policiers en uniforme et lunettes de
soleil comme si les migrants font aussi
partie des déchets
Di Maria nous sommes des êtres humains
pourquoi on ne les aide pas
d'argent je suis une mère célibataire je
travaille dans la construction Dieu me
donne beaucoup de choses dit-elle je
peux en redonner un peu
la messe donne un assemblant d'humanité
les fidèles sont au rendez-vous les
nouveaux arrivants restent dehors à
respect mutuel s'efforgés entre eux les
œuvres caritatives sur place leur donne
à manger à travers un grillage
il faut permettre le libre mouvement des
travailleurs dit-il
bien loin
au Texas on règle le problème migratoire
par l'armée
le gouverneur Greg Abbot parle d'une
invasion qu'il faut contrer
les hélicoptères blackrocks et les C-130
sont en train de déployer des membres
spécialement entraînés de la garde
nationale dit-il leur mission est
d'expulser tout migrants qui entrent de
façon irrégulière au Texas
car on redoute un afflux migratoire avec
l'expiration du titre 42 la mesure
sanitaire prise durant la pandémie pour
envoyer les migrants
Washington va dorénavant appliquer le
titre 8 toute personne qui franchira la
frontière de manière irrégulière sera
renvoyée et ne pourra présenter de
demander d'asile pendant 5 ans
titre 42 titre 8 peu importe le chiffre
ils sont des milliers à roarez à
attendre d'aller de l'autre côté
l'Eldorado américain est à portée de
main et aucun obstacle ne semble les
arrêter
ici Radio-Canada